[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire s'y succèderont aujourd'hui
sur ce plateau j'entends l'historien
bruno fuligni pour le livre les furies
de l'histoire ce sont des femmes qui ont
choisi de rivaliser avec les hommes sur
un terrain qu'ils auraient normalement
réservé celui du meurtre et de la
torture de la violence en général
il y aura ensuite leonardo marcos pour
son exposition en ligne intitulé
primavera et la chica elle était dans
cette émission décembre pour la sortie
de son album la loba elle revient car
elle est enfin de retour sur scène salle
gaveau le 25 juin et ensuite en tournée
dans toute la france pendant tout l'été
alors bruno fuligni on commence tout de
suite par notre époque qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle
voici l'image que vous avez choisi c'est
la fiche du film disney créé la wii
c'est intéressante s'intéresse aux
furies de voir que dans l'actualité ce
personnage qui était totalement
secondaire dans le dessin animé disney
début des années 60 ou dans le roman des
années 50 qui l'a inspiré devient
aujourd'hui la vedette c'est à dire que
ce personnage malfaisant et un peu
ridicule il ya quelques décennies
devient un personnage central est un
personnage
finalement qu'on nous invite à
à suivre quelque chose d'attachant avec
l'idée est bien qu'on ne réussit pas en
étant gentil donc on peut suivre une
certaine vision de la femme à travers
ces deux jalons
alors on peut se dire que les studios
disney ont bien changé ou alors eh bien
on est passé comment dirais-je d'un lieu
commun à un autre d'une norme sociale à
une autre en tout cas c'est assez
extraordinaire est révélateur je trouve
de voir cette apothéose de cruella
aujourd'hui les faits de l'histoire ça
paraît aux éditions first
vous avez choisi comment vos furets de
l'histoire parce que là on est plus dans
la méchante gentil la joyeuse
malfaisante
c'est dé vous avez vu nous mettre en
exergue des vrais vrai vrai meurtrière à
des hypers méchant et s'attellent à la
consigne puisque est un ouvrage
collectif
les quinze auteurs ont rivalisé un petit
peu dans la recherche de la plus cruelle
la plus sadique la plus méchante
donc il fallait déjà qu'elle ait tué
plusieurs personnes tant qu'à faire
et puis surtout qu'elle l'ait fait je
dirais avec une forme effectivement de
cruauté de sadisme une absence totale de
scrupules
pourquoi parce que dans la même
collection précédemment nous avions la
même équipe nous avions traité les rois
fou nous avions traité les affreux de
l'histoire et en fait c'était presque
exclusivement des portraits masculins
eh bien il ya une parité une égalité
également dans l'horreur et c'est ce que
nous voulons montrer avec les fut riche
histoire je vous arrête vous exagérez un
peu les prisons sont pleines à 96 %
d'hommes partout dans le monde
donc à égalité non à l'attention parce
que
bon il ya une petite délinquance qui
remplit beaucoup les prisons mais la
très grande délinquance le crime le
crime en série l'infanticide ce genre de
choses c'est assez bien répartis
en fait c'est un préjugé qui fait qu' on
a du mal à considérer qu'il ya des
femmes criminelles
à l'époque il y avait la peine de mort
il y avait très peu de femmes qui a été
guillotiné en fait parce que les jurés
avaient peur de condamner des femmes à
mort mais il y avait des femmes qui tu
es aussi des empoisonneuses des sadiques
de toutes sortes et en fait c'est
vraiment une représentation mentale que
nous avons l'idée quand même que la
femme quelque part est gentil et que si
par hasard elle est méchante c'est parce
que c'est une victime qui se venge
mais en réalité il y a eu des des femmes
qui ont brillé par une extrême violence
à travers le temps mais alors justement
commençons par y en a trois qui sont au
début de ce livre et moi je les range
plutôt à la catégorie de celles qui ont
été victimes au départ et qui sont
devenus méchante plus ou moins pour se
venger ou pour ou pour se défendre de
leur mari alors il ya clytemnestre ya
agrippine eia frédégonde alors on va les
voir dans l'ordre d'abord clytemnestre
rap et nous deux qui il s'agit et
pourquoi elle est si méchante alors
clytemnestre évidemment
omer nous en a dressé un portrait au
vitriol
en parlant de la guerre de troie
pourquoi parce que c'est la femme
d'agamemnon alors effectivement elle
n'est pas tout de suite
arrivé comme cela dans le lit
d'agamemnon agamemnon a tué son
précédent mari et a fait d'elle un peu
de force sa femme donc effectivement
elle a une vengeance à tirer elle a une
double vengeance à tirer puisque au
moment où donc ils y vont combattre vos
faire le siège de troie il ya ce
problème de manque de vent qu'on imagine
de résoudre par le sacrifice d'iphigénie
iphigénie c'est la fille de clytemnestre
dont clytemnestre a de bonnes raisons
d'en vouloir à agamemnon c'est
indéniable mais
ma foi c'est pas un enfant de choeur non
plus lorsque agamemnon guerroient et
bien elle elle l'attend à mycènes avec
egis tu as peu son ministre en quelque
sorte qui devient son amant et lorsque
agamemnon rentrer eh bien il va être
cruellement assassinés agamemnon est
rentré à ne pas rentrer seul est pas
rentré seul mais enfin c'est pas
forcément la meilleure façon de régler
les disputes conjugales un le le meurtre
de masse il est rentré avec en
particulier cassandre fille de priam qui
était une captive mais dont il était
tombé quelques peu amoureux dans les
moeurs de l'époque ça pouvait
éventuellement se concevoir
elle est égorgé sous ses yeux par park
été mené est alors quitte à n'être c'est
peut-être la plus victimes effectivement
de toute la série parce qu'elle se situe
dans la tragédie des atrides une famille
entière qui dans la mythologie grecque
et est frappé de malédiction
et c'est finalement sa propre mort par
son propre fils taux restent vengeant
agamemnon qui va clore cette malédiction
des atrides il n'empêche le doute n est
reste et on voit aussi dans
l'iconographie l'une des plus anciennes
images de ces femmes fortes qui ont
recours à la violence pour essayer
d'inverser le cours du destin
agrippine est plus connu c'est la mère
de néron agrippine donc elle va d'abord
se débrouiller pour que son fils néron
deviennent empereur elle est prête à
tout pour ça et ensuite c'est le héros
qui sera prêt à tout pour se débarrasser
des albères
oui on l'a on est effectivement dans les
moeurs de 7,2 cette rome décadente qui
font un petit peu frémir ce qui a
surtout rendu
le souvenir vague hippie d'un petit peu
encombrant c'est que finalement elle va
séduire l'empereur claude pour accéder
au pouvoir
claude et son oncle et son oncle et
marie elles valent empoisonné pour en
quelque sorte prendre sa place et pour
promouvoir son fils
mais là aussi elle va le payer cher is
que son fils va se retourner il aura du
mal à l'assassiner est résistant elle
est résistante et il fallait être
résistant toute façon époque là où elle
retrouve la toison le poignard les
ballets ya frédégonde moi je me suis
dans mon livre d'histoire quand j'étais
enfant il y avait frédégonde et brunet
au et c'était presque les deux figures
qu'on avait retenu des mérovingiens en
souvenez jamais de leur nom aux
mérovingiens à ces rois mérovingiens et
au souvenez que de leur raid était
beaucoup plus vaillantes quelques oeufs
en effet c'est vrai que là on a comment
dirais-je quasiment un scénario de série
qui est écrit dans l'histoire puisque
frédégonde d'une part et bruno d'autre
part ce sont deux reines qui vont
s'affronter par marie interposés et puis
à la fin bon frédégonde va avoir liquidé
son propre mari donc elle va régner elle
même et ce sont vraiment deux rivales
qui comment dirais-je se combattent
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque donc la
horde et au vième siècle
il ya une règle de succession
complètement aberrante chez les
mérovingiens qui fait que quand un roi
meurt le royaume est partagé entre ses
fils oui mais c'est csn est une
structure familiale qui nous a bien
rendu service à nous payer parce que
c'est égalitaire c'est dégueulasse c'est
vrai si on lit emmanuel todd c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avais peut-être
mais à l'époque ça s'est traduit quand
même par d'assez joli bain de sang
d'abord les frères et des soeurs donc
une idée c'est éliminer le reste de la
fratrie pour avoir tout le royaume
et puis ça occasionnait un certain
nombre de guerre dans le cas de frais
des goudes c'est encore plus particulier
parce qu'elle elle n'appartient pas aux
familles royales
alors que bruno est une princesse
wisigothe qui a été épousée par un roi
francis gibert elles au fond c'est juste
la servante et le de la reine qui
épousent dechy les aciers très belle vue
les servantes qui s'élève un peu trop
bas sinon que c'est un cas très précoce
de méritocratie bien avant la république
puisque effectivement elle va faire de
la place
va réussir très astucieusement à
assortir os de verre donc la femme du
roi chilpéric du lit du roi parce
qu'elles valent à convaincre d'être la
marraine de sa propre fille ce qui fait
qu'elle devient commères et donc c'est
presque ce serait presque une forme
d'inceste pour le roi que de partager sa
couche avec celle qui est quand même sa
femme donc elle est doucement écarté
plus tard elle sera physiquement
éliminer ainsi que sa fille n'aura servi
qu'à ça alors bon chilpéric très console
à bhl a tout de suite pris une deuxième
femme
galvin mais qu'on va retrouver
mystérieusement étranglée dans son lit
donc au bout d'un moment vont passer
frédégonde qui s'impose est la servante
de la première reine devient reine
elle-même et elle va passer son temps a
poussé son mari à toutes sortes
d'actions de d'assassinât de guerre
contre celui qui est quand même son
frère 1,6 berre et à la fin et bien
finalement ayant éliminé à peu près tout
le monde y compris chilpéric lui même et
bien frédégonde va mourir dans son lit
elle meurt dans son lit c'est bruno qui
finit à attacher à l'est que d'un cheval
oui parce que il ya un petit sens de la
famille et il se trouve que frédégonde
avait un fils clotaire 2 si je ne me
trompe et clotaire va poursuite la
guerre contre bruno fini par s'emparer
de bruno elle a 80 ans agen incroyable à
cette époque là et elle va être cette
pauvre bruno va être promené nu à dos de
chameau et ensuite attaché un cheval au
galop et son son corps
pantelant sanguinaire sanglant pardon et
bien sera brûlé il ya dans votre série
dans votre livre évidemment les serial
killeuse alors y en a beaucoup moins des
hommes mais y en a quand même mais alors
y en a une que tout le monde connaît pas
ce qu'on nous la ressort à chaque fois c
est bête bathory qui a été l'objet de
quantité de films d'une comtesse
hongroise qui va finir ses jours
ensuite une fois qu'on aura découvert le
nombre de de gens qui avaient fait
assassiner elle va finir je crois muré
dans son propre château lui ou lui
passer l'air pas juste par un trou
n'avait muret qu'entièrement elle va
être complètement folle elle va y passer
quatre ans elle va disparaître bien leur
y en a une que je ne connaissais pas qui
est une autre comtesse sanglante sont
laids et qui est les russes moskovitz et
la comtesse celtico va alors l'une par
rapport à l'autre laquelle est la plus
cruelle qu'elle est la plus furieuse
voilà alors s est dit qu elles vivent à
un siècle différent si cela va avec
fb de bathory on est à fin du xvième
début du xviie siècle alors qu avec
daria zhukova on est en plein xviiie
siècle l'une est une comtesse en gros
hongroise dans la partie qui va de la
hongrie aux balkans et r&b de bathory a
eu plus de succès je dirais en dehors
des frontières un petit peu à travers le
monde
sans doute parce qu'elle préfigure un
petit peu les soins esthétiques puisque
outre ces cruautés je dirais banale elle
s'était mise en tête que du sang de
jeunes filles pouvaient aussi elle se
baignait dedans lui préservé
éternellement sont 1 la beauté de sa
peau c'est ce qu'il y avait eu un
certain succès cinématographiques par
exemple avant huit films et le ban se re
valérien de bauxite le fait je crois que
c'était paloma picasso des eaux qui
jouait le rôle de lisbeth bathory avait
un roman de valentine penrose la
comtesse sanglante dont elle a eu une
certaine renommée dans le cas de la
celtic au vin on n'est plus dans du
sadisme ordinaire mais tout de même
elle a été condamnée pour 38 assassinat
avérée on pense en réalité qui lie à 138
victime alors presque exclusivement des
femmes seulement trois hommes surtout de
très jeunes femmes et même des enfants
c'est tout simplement une aristocrate de
de cette époque là en russie où on
pratique encore le servage uns servent
c'est rien ça n'a pas vocation à aller
se plaindre
et pourtant trois iront quand même se
plaindre mais à la bonne porte
et que va-t-il se passer et bien chaque
fois qu'il y à un menu manquement au
service les châtiments pleuvent
c'est du sadisme avant la lettre un très
clairement et par exemple elle valait à
elle va battre elle va trucider elle va
faire mourir certaines de ses servantes
en les laissant nu dehors en plein hiver
donc évidemment dans la banlieue de
moscou où vous voyez ce que ça peut
donner
c'est épouvantable et ce qui va se
passer c'est que l'un de ses
et palefrenier qui est certain et link
avait un certain courage a eu trois
femmes successives tué par daria salle
tycho bas et donc il a fait quelque
chose d'extrêmement dangereux pour acer
fils a quitté la propriété donc il était
considéré comme serpent suis en fuite
il est allé à saint pétersbourg et là il
a demandé à rencontrer catherine 2 tout
simplement l'impératrice arles où
j'apparais incroyable mais il tombe au
bon moment
au moment où commence à s'affirmer ou se
réaffirmer un pouvoir central une grande
catherine qui veut montrer aux nobles
que il ya un pouvoir central et qu'ils
ne peuvent pas faire n'importe quoi
complètement n'importe quoi sur leurs
terres et du coup ça va être cette
classe finalement cette supplique date
un pauvre ses enfants suite va
déclencher une véritable enquête avec un
magistrat qui est absolument effarés de
ce qu'il découvre et de la même façon
que r&b de bathory et bien derrière
cette co va être condamné car elle ne va
pas être exécutée mais elle va la plus
grande sincérité parce que ce sont des
nobles à laquelle appartiennent à la
tribu sont des femmes aussi donc c'était
compliqué finalement génère une affaire
qui ressemble un petit peu à gilles de
rais en france mais en plus ce sont des
femmes
donc on ne tue pas et elle va être d'une
certaine manière également en murray
vivant dans
dans une pièce où il y aura une petite
fenêtre et on ira la voir et elle est
devenue une espèce de sorcières de
personnages un peu fantasmatique de la
culture populaire ou de la mémoire
populaire russe il ya une équipe une
équivalente ces deux là mais un siècle
plus tard c'est delphine la lorie qui
elle aussi a des esclaves mais c'est en
louisiane aux etats unis et et ses
esclaves elle n'hésite pas à les
torturer
c'est absolument infâme mais c'est
finalement elle rentre dans cette
catégorie la personne qui a sans doute
un tempérament effectivement pervers
sadique et qui a tout pouvoir sur des
personnes totalement privés de droits
des esclaves là en l'occurrence on est
en louisiane alors ça a choqué encore
plus parce que l'heure n'était pas dans
une propriété lointaine on était au
coeur de la nouvelle d'avoir des valeurs
les ans on va voir la maison d'ailleurs
je la connais doit être allé
nouvelle-orléans vin que je croit la
connaître et je jouais très bien au
royal et c'est devenu une attraction
c'est devenu une attraction touristique
et un petit peu une maison de l'horreur
à dire qu'on a fait peser peut-être
aussi sur les épaules de delphine
lalaurie toute l'horreur de l' esclavage
dans la louisiane et dans le sud des
états unis à partir d'un fait divers
alors ce fait divers il éclate en 1834
il ya un incendie qui est allumée dans
sa maison et lorsque les secours
arrivent ils ont la surprise de
découvrir une véritable salle de torture
avec au moins cet esclave qui sont dans
la salle de tortures qui sont mutilés
qui ont les membres des formes et qui
sont là depuis des mois à subir des
supplices après la légende va s'emparer
de cette histoire en fait contrairement
au cas de la kova il n'y aura pas de
procès parce que delphine alors il va
réussir à disparaître
et donc elle devient d'autant plus un
personnage maléfique mystérieux et un
peu légendaire qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment ce qu'elle est devenue
elle a sans doute trouvé refuge en
france n'oublions pas que la louisiane
était une ancienne possession française
elle parlait évidemment le français elle
s'est sans doute fondu dans le décor à
paris elle n'a jamais eu à répondre de
ses crimes qui du coup se sont un peu
multiplié les cet esclave initiaux on
est passé à des centaines ya des textes
assez fou
qui décrivent cette maison de l'horreur
mais la taille de la maison rend ces
textes sans doute peu crédible néanmoins
cette d'ogre femelle de la
nouvelle-orléans esclavagiste fait
partie de ces figures noires
que sont ces furies qu'on retrouve
finalement sur tous les continents et à
toutes les époques du moment que une
femme comme un homme qui n'a plus aucun
contre-pouvoir qui n'a plus aucune
autorité en face d'elle pour s'opposer à
ses désirs et bien peu écrasée des
personnes qui sont à sa merci
il ya louise bessat rabot qui figurent
dans ce livre qui connaissent souvent
comparé à landru ne serait ce que parce
que je crois que le même juge
d'instruction que landru avait enquêté
sur elle le même président du tribunal
s'est retrouvé à la juger elle a pris le
même avocat que landru le célèbre aux
affaires moreau giafferi et mais bon ces
crimes à elle était quand même beaucoup
progressé il s'agit d'une balle
sanglante
c'est pas la cuisinière de granby quand
même alors elle a été peut-être repéré
plutôt bon louise bessat rabbo
effectivement elle doit ce surnom de
landru féminin aussi à la concordance
des dates puisque la faire éclater au
moment où on est en train d'instruire
puis de juger landru et il ya un
parallélisme assez troublant entre
landru donc l'homme qui faisait
disparaître ses fiancés et louise bédard
a beau qu'on a soupçonné de faire
disparaître ces maris alors quand je lis
et marie soyons précis
en fait il y en a un qui a clairement
disparu son chauffeur vient alerter la
police
on retrouve le corps ligoté dans une
malle qui a été envoyé en train dans
l'est de la france
simplement on se rend compte en
enquêtant que
louise bessard à bout du nom de son mari
était préalablement mariée à un autre
homme qui lui aussi alors s'est suicidé
mais dans des circonstances tout de même
extrêmement trou alors on n'arrivera
jamais à prouver qu'elle est à l'origine
d'un faux suicide mais il ya quand même
un certain nombre d'éléments très très
troublant alors ce qui va beaucoup
occupé les esprits à cette époque là
c'est que louise bessat rabot qui à
partir plus tôt à la grande bourgeoisie
c'est une barcelonnette un fait partie
de ces familles de français qui ont fait
fortune au mexique elle a vécu entre le
mexique et la france
et bien cette louise mais ça rabot est
aussi un auteur qui écrit des textes
ultra féministe sous un pseudonyme
troublant ra myrte l era la femme de
zeus m'indiquer tigres aux missionnaires
pensionnaires qui voulaient qui a tenté
de faire ligoté deux par ses enfants
donc et on a lu des textes qui
honnêtement était très très
confidentielle à l'époque mais qui ont
quand même beaucoup intrigué le juge
d'instruction parce qu'en fait c'était
pas comment dirais-je hindous féminisme
visant à réaliser l'égalité des droits
la thèse de louise bédard a bossé qu
autrefois renier le matriarcat que les
femmes ont été dépossédés du pouvoir par
les hommes qui sont ce qu'il ya quand
même de pire au monde et qu'elles ont
vocation à reprendre le pouvoir et a
écrasé les hommes et à imposer la
suprématie féminine donc on s'est
demandé si dans la sphère domestique au
moins elle n'avait pas cherché à
réaliser ce programme qu'elle avait fixé
noir sur blanc il faut dire aussi
qu'elle est la tante de l'abbé pierre
oui c'est peu connu mais
l'abbé l'abbé pierre de son vrai nom
henri grouès est effectivement le neveu
de louise grouès
il est lui aussi issu de ces familles de
barcelonnette ans lui a rompu avec ce
milieu là la question que je me suis
posée à laquelle je n'ai pas trouvé de
réponse c'est ce qu'il n'a pas aussi
consacré sa vie ou bien et à la prière
un petit peu pour racheter pour expier
les crimes de tati louise alors il ya
danger à tad qui elle est une voleuse
d'enfants de la pire espèce d'ailleurs
une sale tête c'est un peu l'arche de
zoé mais industriels
il me semble que dans ce panorama des
furies c'est sans doute la pire et la
pire justement parce qu'elle n'est pas
violente quand on la voit on dirait une
mamie américaine qui prépare le thé
un gâteau aux pommes bon qui va vous
recevoir et qui va ou pas parler du
temps en fait c'est un criminel
redoutable redoutable que georgia thann
simplement elle maîtrise les arcanes du
droit et de la loi
c'est la fille d'un juge dès sa petite
enfance elle a vu et compris comment
fonctionnaient les tribunaux et en
particulier les décisions d'adoption et
ayant compris comment on pouvait
déposséder une femme seule une femme
alcoolique une folle une famille pauvre
de ses enfants elle va en faire un
véritable business
alors il ya une façade tout à fait
estimable
elle travaille pour une sorte de
fondation a chargé de placer des enfants
sans famille à memphis dans le tennessee
on adhère en payant 7 $ tout ça à l'air
caritatif et bienveillant mais derrière
il y a des roises terrifiant les enfants
en fait sont vendus compter 5000 dollars
de l'époque on est entre les années 20
et la fin des années quarante cinq mille
dollars de l'époque pour pour un enfant
ses enfants certains sont
comment dirais-je de véritables
orphelins quel voilà qu'elle va chercher
dans les orphelinats
d'autres sont si je puis dire des
orphelins provoquer c'est à dire des
enfants qu'elle fait enlever kidnapper
des enfants qui sont déclarés mort né à
de pauvres femmes qui accouchent dans
des circonstances difficiles et qui en
fait sont rabattus vers elle pour servir
de marchandises
et alors ce qui est véritablement
épouvantable c'est que non seulement
elle a brassé comme cela on estime à
environ 3000 enfants vendu à 5000 $
pièce je vous laisse faire le calcul à
un marché de 2 15 millions de dollars de
l'époque mais il y avait quand même une
partie de la marchandise si j'ose dire
qu'ils ne trouvaient pas preneurs les
enfants vraiment trop chétif pas assez
mignon trop triste et bien cela elle est
laissée mourir et
on estime qu'il y a plus sans doute
environ 300 corps de bébé ou de très
jeunes enfants encore enfouis dans les
sous sols de sa fondation et l'a échappé
belle et justice selon elle a totalement
échappé à la justice alors en 1949 un
nouveau gouverneur avant elle avait des
protections politiques
un nouveau gouverneur sent que quelque
chose ne va pas il ya quand même
quelques maires qui sont convaincus que
leur enfant n'est pas mort sinon elle
aurait vu le gore et des poursuites qui
sont engagés des complices de georgia
vont vont devoir démissionner vont
devoir rendre compte mais elle meurt et
l'ironie de l'histoire c'est que elle
meurt d'un cancer de l'utérus avant tout
procès et toute condamnation
elle est donc toujours présumée
innocente aujourd'hui par raccroc et
dernière alors y en a bien une bien
d'autres dans votre livre mais il ya
deux mika walter il se trouve qu'on en
reparle en ce moment même parce que
christine clerc lui a consacré un livre
dominique à la diabolique alors c'est
elle qu'on voit pas ce qu'il y avait eu
un autre livre précédemment qui lui
était consacré on la voit là c'était
l'un sur un tableau que avait fait le
peintre andré derain d'elle la femme au
chapeau est alors lll c'est incroyable
parce que de cette jeune fille de
l'aveyron monter à paris à 19 ans fille
de clerc de notaire épouse un très grand
collectionneur jeunes d'ailleurs ils se
marient en 1920 elle va hériter sa
collection elle va elle va faire
disparaître probablement le premier mari
le deuxième mari qui est un milliardaire
célèbre l'architecte jean valter qui a
fait fortune avec une mine
elle va lui aussi probablement le faire
disparaître et elle a même essayé de
faire mourir son fils adoptif qu'elle
avait adoptée uniquement pour pour que
la collection la fameuse collection de
peintures ne lui échappe pas la crap
deux collections ses 156 à peu près
tableaux magnifiques qui vont faire le
musée de l'orangerie quasiment elle est
extraordinaire l on l'a oublié
aujourd'hui
incroyable oui c'est un personnage
assez grandiose très belle on a aussi
qu'elle a inspiré des peintres très
élégante son premier mari paul guillaume
tombe amoureux d'elle alors qu'elle est
une simple fille de vestiaire comme on
disait à l'époque
bon ils les poussent ils ont sept ans de
différence mais vous l'avez dit sont
jeunes tous les deux et puis petit à
petit elle va s'emparer de tous les le
premier mari
le deuxième mari tous les deux meurt
dans des circonstances plus que plus que
trouble vous l'avez dit elle à l as
torpillé un projet de fondations qui ma
foi lui aurait fait perdre les tableaux
la collection en sortant du chapeau
littéralement un fils du premier mari ce
fils en fait elle l'avait achetée c'est
pas à georgia tab mais son équivalent
français et ensuite la laisser un petit
peu
partir dans la nature puis plus tard
lorsque le fils devenus adultes majeurs
se manifeste tout simplement elle elle
se débrouille pour le faire liquider et
elle le médecin parce qu'il est
évidemment un médecin complices dans
l'assassinât du deuxième mari et son
frère vont recruter un tueur à gages
alors c'est un légionnaire le fils lui
même est passé par la légion donc le
tueur à gages empoche l'argent mais ne
tue pas et va même prévenir le jeune
homme que sa mère entre guillemets et
son entourage et bien prévoit de le
faire liquider
ils ne seront pas condamnés parce que
figurez-vous qu'en france il est il
n'est pas punissable de faire appel à un
tueur à gages ce n'est pas prévu dans le
code est donc certain temps on
n'a pas un vrai crime la seule intention
même avec le recours de quelqu'un qui se
propose comme tueur à gages ça ne suffit
pas incriminer volent et donc tout le
monde sait qu'elle a essayé de faire
tuer son fils qui n'était pas son fils
elle l'a dit elle même à son fils en
fait elle avait choisi comme un petit
chiot exact exactement et malgré elle ne
sera jamais rejoint par là par la loi et
puis alors il ya cette histoire très
trouble en 1957 a donc à la mort du
second du second mari c'est cette
collection qui va devenir une collection
publique
on sait que dominique a fréquenté andré
malraux qu'il déjeunait on se demande si
à partir de 1958 malraux devenant
ministre qui plus est aux affaires
culturelles
il ya eu un arrangement
une certaine compréhension des autorités
publiques contre et bien cette
collection tout de même fabuleuse à la
garde jusqu'à sa mort elle n'a jamais
phd fait par la justice et l'état
français a attendu qu'elle meure pour
pouvoir prendre la collection et on peut
la voir aujourd'hui au musée de
l'orangerie
merci bruno fuligni les furies de
l'histoire il y en ad'autres vous
rassure ça vient de paraître aux
éditions first on se retrouve juste
après une pause avec leonardo marcos
[Musique]
leonardo marcos vous êtes un artiste
numérique vous réalisez des vidéos des
photos des installations des poèmes
digitaux et last but not least votre
nouvelle exprime position primavera se
visite en ligne on va la découvrir dans
un instant mais d'abord une image que
vous avez choisi pour symboliser notre
époque
elle me fait bien plaisir parce que ça
fait longtemps que j'ai envie d'en
parler ce sont les laits futur taxi
volanges du futur mais ils sont déjà là
ils existent ils ont été testés en
france enfin pas dans le ciel mais mais
on attend les autorisations et on ne
pourra bientôt prendre un taxi volant
poil l aéroport par exemple c'est une
chance et pourquoi est ce que ça vous
symbolise pour vous pourquoi ça
symbolise notre époque ça symbolise
notre époque parce que je trouve que les
taxis existe depuis très longtemps bien
sûr c'est quelque chose de finalement
d'ancestrales leur entre guillemets et
le fait que ces taxis vol ça devient
quelque chose de fantastique
et donc là j'aime bien le mariage des
deux c'est à dire le passé et le présent
et l'avenir voilà enfin le passé et
l'avenir
et surtout elle et se dire que c'est un
avenir quand même assez proche
ah oui puisque ça pour elle c'est une
des questions que d'autorisation ça
pourrait marcher très très vite et sans
pilote non plus à rabat on sait que
générera dedans et ce ne sera pas si
cher que ça dans la rue ça qu'on ne le
croit on faire la concurrence des motos
taxis y aurait exactement et bien
commençons à parler de votre exposition
alors c'est une exposition uniquement en
ligne
pourtant les galeries sont ouvertes
alors pourquoi cette exposition est elle
uniquement en ligne
tout simplement parce que
j'ai travaillé ses créations pendant la
période de la pandémie enfin korda
pandémie on sert tous retrouvés confiné
je me suis dit bon après avoir fait
plein de création est ce que je les
présente dans une galerie alors même que
j'avais fait des choses plutôt digital
alors je me suis dit non finalement faut
garder un petit peu cet esprit comme 108
cloud digital et en même temps tout à
fait nouveau et j'ai eu plutôt envie de
le faire dans le cadre d'une web d'un
site internet plutôt qu'une galerie ceci
étant il ya comme une galeriste derrière
qui émilie ducharme et c'est une galerie
nomade c'est ça les galeristes à
bruxelles elle a créé une galerie nomade
mais je propose de faire une visite
courte visite de l'expo vous allez
pouvoir nous l'a commenté ben voilà ce
qui se passe quand vous allez sur le
site et voilà la galerie virtuelle dans
laquelle vous pouvez vous promener de
cette façon-là en battant les gens
savent se promener comme ça dans les
dents les galeries racontez nous
leonardo d'abord est-ce que cet endroit
existe alors oui celui là existe mais
dans le site il ya des endroits que j'ai
inventés qui n'existent pas alors on ne
sait plus qui est réel ou pas real c'est
ce que j'aime bien celui-là est réel
effectivement la fille est réel alors on
peut y visionner des photos des films on
clique
évidemment comme dans fabre c'est un
procédé que tout le monde connaît mais
au fond que qui utilisent assez peu les
artistes
absolument mais c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
intéressant mais de le fait d'être un
peu enfermé pendant le confinement ça
m'a donné l'envi justement d'aller
explorer ces ses possibilités de visite
virtuelle immersive de l'interactif chez
moi là par exemple c'est chez moi voyez
c'est ça c'est là est fausse je ne
bloque pas le dire je devrai laisser le
mystère mais bon c'est le site est
purement inventer des rituels et ça
ouvre des possibilités quand même
extraordinaire je suis étonné qu'on eût
été que les artistes parce que d'autres
utilisent et que les artistes ne
l'utilisent pas davantage ça m'étonne
beaucoup à massat si je peux pas
répondre pour autant qu'en ce qui me
concerne oui j'adore ça et actuellement
je travaille même sur des photos
panoramiques
hic dans lesquelles j'ai introduit des
contenus c'est à dire où finalement
regardons une photographie on peut aller
chercher des points dans ces points en
cliquant granger rentrer quelque chose
voile comme les liens hypertextes dans
les textes ça fonctionne exactement
voilà des vidéos qui sont vous feront
partie des vidéos que l'on peut voir
dans l'exposition
vous les avez toutes réalisées pendant
le confinement alors en grande partie
tout n'a pas été réalisée pendant le
confinement mais en grande partie
effectivement moi j'ai été très très
frustré en tant qu'artiste mais comme
beaucoup d'artistes j'imagine du fait
que tous les événements sont arrêtés
tout d'un coup il y avait sorte de
silence de mort aux rats à tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire d'événementiel j'avais
même un une programmation au silencio
qui s'appelait justement la primavera le
jour du printemps et puis voilà quelques
jours après ben c'était c'est tel
confinement
donc j'ai commencé à travailler dans des
intérieurs c'est bien mais après tout
finalement c'est pas parce que on est
enfermé qu'on peut pas créer alors je me
suis amusé à créer comme je pouvais avec
les moyens du bord
et puis j'ai été un peu plus loin en
cherchant aussi des images souvenirs
c'est à dire des images que j'avais fait
des images un peu de deux films
souvenirs amoureux
voilà en super 8 et puis j'ai revisité
d'une autre hd et transformer une
certaine manière et je les ai intégré
dans ses visites virtuelles et tout d'un
coup c'est devenu une vraie oeuvre
digitale complète dans ces moments qui
était très très difficile
alors quand je regarde ça qui n'est pas
ça y est vous pour moi il ya un érotisme
qui me rappelle un peu celui qui qui qui
avaient du succès dans les années 70
sont nés avant le porno chic alors je
sais que dans ce qui concerne votre
travail en vous on vous compare souvent
l'art sensualiste oui moi je vois
d'abord et avant tout l'érotisme des
années 70 après côté je suis ravie vous
me disiez ça faisait bien le premier
parce que je me revendique complètement
de cette période là de cet érotisme là
qu'était un érotisme
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus le terme
charme brisait le char ont parlé des
magazines de charme il
et tout ça c'était du magazine de charme
et aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus donc ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes très puritain soit
vous êtes dans le porno mais il n'ya à
cette troisième voie qui était le charme
et et c'était une époque très très belle
au niveau esthétique ce que si on
regarde les grands photographes des
années 70 il était dans ce charme là et
moi je suis un peu un enfant de cette
voie là de cette génération là qu'est ce
qu'on peut acheter dans votre galerie
virtuelle jusqu'au normalement quand on
fait une exposition dans une des règles
c'est pour mordre au trésor
évidemment ça va se passer différemment
écoutez il ya vingt ans quand j'ai
commencé à faire de l'oeil à créer de
l'art digital légal risque j'allais
enfin que ce que je rencontrais me
disais mais on pense à comment une
espèce de moi même je savais pas je
crème et je ne savais pas trop comment
on pouvait le vent alors au début
c'étaient les événements c'est à dire la
mise en scène
voilà donc on pouvait trouver acheter un
dvd ou à l'époque même une cassette
vidéo
il ya eu déjà des cassettes vidéo vers
ces cassettes vidéo mais aujourd'hui
c'est tout à fait différent
aujourd'hui l'art digital est en train
de de s'intégrer dans un marché de la
très puissant ultra puissant mais en
fait c'est les mêmes questionnements
qu'on avait avec le le street art
le street art c'était des gens qui
allaient sur des murs graf et quelque
chose et puis on se disait ça on va
jamais le vendre puis quand on voit les
résultats de lens qui aujourd'hui en
terme de vente s'érodent remarquable et
bien la même chose est arrivée avec le
enfin c'est très récent avec l'art
digital c'est à dire qu'en fait la revue
digital aujourd'hui on peut le vendre
sous une forme très particulière c'est
ce qu'on appelle nft la blocs chaîne et
s'est adapté en français ce sont les
jetons non jetons gibles là exactement
et donc il ya aujourd'hui un système de
protection de l'oeuvre qui permet en
fait de devenir une marchandise en fait
oui c'est à dire qu'à être d'être
uniques et signées dès l'instant où vous
êtes uniques et signées évidemment soit
là quelqu'un peut en être propriétaire
il ya eu le vrai boom c'est d'ailleurs
pendant la pandémie qui a eu le moon sur
les annexer le people l'artiste qui a
vendu pour 60 millions de dollars
une oeuvre quelques lignes de code enfin
jusqu'à la fin on achète des lignes de
code et alors là ça tout le monde super
coup s'est dit tiens il se passe quelque
chose il ya jack dorsey le pdg de
twitter qui a vendu son premier tweet
2,9 millions de dollars vous vous êtes à
quel prix ah non non j'ai en fait c'est
ça varie selon les zones
en fait c'est très difficile justement
de aujourd'hui de poser un chiffre sur
une oeuvre digital ça peut être très
très cher mais ça peut aussi tout dépend
voilà deux du contexte
aujourd'hui on est vraiment les
pionniers par rapport à ce qui est
marchand un bien sûr c'est tout à fait
nouveau donc
donc voilà on explore voilà tous ces
gens là en fait ça permet de vendre tous
les biens immatériels et donc les photos
les il ya d un groupe qui a vendu son
album ça n'empêche pas que moi j'ai son
album aussi je vais essayer beaucoup
moins cher mais quelqu'un a décidé
d'être propriétaire du nfc de l'album de
cet artiste
on peut vendre ses clips oui ça ouvre
des perspectives extraordinaires mais
mais c'est pour l'instant des
collectionneurs un peu particulier oui
ce sont des collections en particulier
après ça peut être aussi des entreprises
moi je sais que quand j'ai commencé à
vraiment à rendre pérennes l'art digital
parce qu'au début il y avait aussi des
problèmes technologiques c'est à dire
que l'art digital mois au début c'était
quelque chose que je réalisais plutôt
dans le contexte des événements type la
nuit blanche le printemps des poètes
tout ça et puis avec le temps avec la
technologie qui évolue on a réussi à
avoir des ddv pis qu'avec des
vidéoprojecteurs qui permettent de
diffuser en fait dès votre oeuvre de
manière pérenne c'est assez in situ et
pérenne et non plus éphémère ça c'est
très important au delà de ce que l'on
peut voir dans sur internet et ça ça a
été très important m'a par exemple j'ai
une oeuvre qui depuis 3 4 ans et
présente au crédit agricole est quand
même une belle maison caci pour être
encore plus précis voilà qui tous les
jours diffuse en fait un poème digital
que j'ai réalisé un haïku qui est
diffusée dans plusieurs langues telles
que je les conçu et donc il ya tous les
jours des eaux des centaines et milliers
de personnes qui passent et qui découvre
un pot est mort je me dis c'est génial
parce que finalement ça démocratise un
peu la poésie
on la rend dans digital alors que pour
retrouver cette exposition virtuelle
l'adresse c'est la primavera by leonardo
tout attaché point fr j'insiste parce
que j'ai du mal à le trouver mais après
on peut se retrouver dans des magasins
de meubles et c'est donc la primavera by
leonardo point fr tout attaché ou alors
on passe par la galerie emilie du jeune
donc les favoris à l'arrivée elle est
une galerie érotique au départ oui c'est
une galerie qui se revendiquait érotique
l'est un peu moins je crois aujourd'hui
c'est plus ouvert en fait c'est plus
large mais qui effectivement été une
galerie qui y avait cette taxe la cet
angle-là de valade sachant que le juge
d'après ce qu'on a vu vous cet impératif
c'est du charme puisque d'érotique à je
revendique plus le charme que l'érotisme
oui alors les questions qu'on a un qu'on
a vus ensemble merci leonardo marcos et
jusqu'à quand ben en plus élevé un
avantage c'est que cette exposition qui
durera toute la wii mais oui évidemment
c'est formidable et les oeuvres sont
sont à vendre bien sûr angie et areva ou
si les termes mission ben voilà
[Musique]
la chica vous étiez dans cette émission
décembre dernier au moment de la sortie
de votre album la loba la louve en
espagnol c'est à présent votre grand
retour sur scène vous sera en concert
salle gaveau le 25 juin est en tournée
dans toute la france pour l'été mais
alors vraiment dans toute la france vous
ne ratez aucune ville aucun village
mais on commence tout de suite par
l'image que vous avez choisi pour notre
époque
une oeuvre d'art mais de kif absolument
c'est une oeuvre d'un duo d'artistes
mexicains
il s'appelle masques à gaz et à l'ambré
font partie du collectif mexicain mots
et collectifs qui fabrique des
structures géantes gigantesque en fil de
fer
et j'ai voulu enfin cette photo me plaît
depuis depuis que les yeux sont tombés
dessus parce que elle elle main pacte
beaucoup elle s'appelle attendu j'ai un
petit doute sur le nom de ce que je
voudrais pas me tromper parce que
l'oeuvre toujours important elle
s'appelle l d'eau lol comme 36 yonne al
ahly veulent pas ça veut dire la douleur
comme transition vers la liberté et en
fait j'ai la sensation que c'est
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
vivre là en ce moment on a plutôt bien
que ce soit aux sorcières dans l'autre
la troisième pour part de la liberté
pour aller vers autre chose
hu est clair maintenant là là on est on
a vécu un cri on a vécu un appel
planétaire un appel au changement
un appel à revisiter à ce système qui
marche pas et beaucoup trop de
discriminations de nos considérations de
l'environnement un capitalisme à
outrance est on est on sait perdu
complètement dans ce dents dans cette
période là de de l'humanité et je pense
qu'on est en train d'entrer dans une
nouvelle ère
comme on est en train d'entrer dans une
nouvelle ère on n'a pas encore
complètement terminé cette transition
la transition elle est douloureuse parce
que ça implique de changer et le
changement
lassé implique de changer ça implique de
laisser derrière soi aussi beaucoup de
choses de les laisser mourir
et ça c'est douloureux tout changement
toute transformation et douloureuse
donc ce que je vois en regardant cette
photo c'est un peu l'état dans lequel on
pourrait se trouver actuellement on est
en est en évolution
mais il va falloir lâcher beaucoup de
choses et ça ce sera ça va pas se faire
sans douleur ça va pas se faire sans
peine
si vous dites que c'est vers la liberté
c'est plutôt réjouissant mais c'est sûr
on entre vraiment dans une nouvelle ère
et c'est juste qu'on n'a pas encore les
paramètres en main pour pouvoir savoir
exactement comment ça va se passer
donc on est encore dans cette souffrance
on va regarder tout de suite un extrait
de votre nouveau clip c'est toujours le
même album la loba mais c'est une
chanson qui s'appelle à gordes et
êtes-vous sorti un clip qui a déjà été
énormément vu le regarder un extrait
telle celle au kawa
un duo bien pour elle au ca
la wka madame de con agua fria et sont à
la peine à raimu memoria des minéraux
à
[Musique]
je
tiens
comme à saint jérôme
sa came torrentielles a
[Musique]
sa voix
et ça casse
le molière
[Musique]
à
il y a
ça
ces lots
[Musique]
tous
ça
dur
[Musique]
vous faites sur des clips formidable
celui-là de vous laver tourné avec un
iphone c'est incroyable je vais tourner
avec un téléphone parce que je n'avais
pas prévu de faire un coup mais j'étais
dans une situation de vie où j'avais
besoin d'eux
de m'exprimer j'ai besoin de guérir et
pour moi la guérison elle passe à
travers l'ariège à travers la manière
que je vais avoir de m'exprimer dans ce
que j'avais sous la main à ce moment là
c'était un téléphone et j'ai trouvé ça
super de faire un clip avec un autre
exemple je l'avais déjà diffusés quand
vous êtes venu en décembre mais je
résiste pas au plaisir de le re diffusé
un extrait de la loba la chanson qui
donne son nom à l'album
pour ceux qui l'avaient déjà vu de toute
façon ce sera un autre plaisir que de le
revoir
solomon sous la question nationale et du
bassidj sur la question mais comment
senna médias mt
bon
ap katmandou
après quand je pense à plus quand on
pense aux va trop loin
le prolonge encore loïc aubin mais à la
mag avait des à la maille à celle que tu
aspires talibés la torah vers le polar
est ce qu a sauvé répondent à porter
celle aussi c'est aussi le soir
c'est la canam a je pense comme de
pandora a beaucoup ne pensent qu'au
volant le pommeau l'on exclut loba le
crawl angoisse roland silva
[Musique]
on va
l'eau a créé ses la grave et plus cela
revient transformant la foudre en
meurent travers mes forces à moudre avec
mes forces pour entamer les cadeaux pour
récupérer les cadres diaw répond bella
fils
[Musique]
tchika comme moi je vous ai jamais vus
sur scène et que je me connecte les
clips
je vous dis que forcément sur scène ça
doit être théâtrale et et sanglant mais
non mais non voyons si beaucoup plus
douce que ça non sur scène je dirais que
c'est il ya cette énergie il ya une
grosse énergie c'est beaucoup
d'intensité mais c'est le principe de la
scène c'est d'inviter les gens à
partager un moment donc je suis pas on
peut parler il ya deux ans et qui a fait
une tonne de soja peu plus accessible je
mens sur scène figuration c'était ce
dernier album la loba c'était fou avec
un piano seulement à l'arrière des
coeurs mais c'est d'abord à pied à dos
ce sera la même chose ça me gave au
juste vous et qu'un piano absolument
ouais je me suis je me suis arrangée
pour pour avoir un set avec suffisamment
de relief pour que ce soit intéressant
pendant pendant plus d'une heure
en tout cas moi je moi je prends
beaucoup plaisir ça me fait du bien et
ça ne guérit et mais vous devez vous
sentir libéré la de retourner sur scène
le nombre de dates de la tournée qui
touche leur ensemble tout le monde de
pouvoir
ouais c'est très cool très contente on
tournera bien bosser aussi et
et je pense que je pense qu'on est tous
dans cette attente la chine
les gens ont envie de musique ils ont
ils ont besoin de musique on a déjà
commencé j'ai joué certaines dates là en
province et c'était l'accueil du public
était dingue ça m'a fait un bien fou je
crois que ça nous affaire bien l'info à
tous
vous parlez dans une interview que vous
disiez une poignée de musique en disant
que c'était un acte de psycho magique
qu'est ce que vous entendez parler
psychologie la psycho magie me
connaissait principe de la psycho magie
de ces notions qui est inventé par
alexandre do we lui je veux que john key
moi moi je je dis que c'est un acte de
psycho magie parce que c'est une action
qui à travers l'art va avoir la
particularité de faire du bien de
soigner de guérir et ça puisse rebondir
sur les autres aussi c'est du chabanisme
mais moi j'ai souvent associé le fait de
faire de la musique en fait de faire de
la magie il ya quelque chose de cet
ordre là là un chaman c'est quelqu'un
qui soigne et qui guérit en altérant
notamment les vibrations cas autour de
lui et c'est ce que fait la musique
c'est ce que provoque laissons donc oui
faire de la musique c'est ça peut avoir
des vertus chamanique parce que la
musique soigne musique apaise musique
aide à passer des épreuves difficiles à
musique sauve par moments vous avez fait
partie d'un groupe au nom quasi
pornographique l'eswi sommes sisters et
je crois que ça existe plus mais là
aussi partout vous êtes ya toujours des
clips formidable on va regarder un
extrait de fall apart
c'est totalement votre univers je me dis
c'est toujours les chick a été fait
différente
[Musique]
la chica on se demande souvent quel que
soit le style de notre époque des années
2020 et quand je me regarde
mais c'est peut-être vous le style des
années 2020 on a beaucoup plus mince
alors
mais vous ne voyez vous comment le style
d'aisé 2020 donc on connait style années
60 le style des années 70 tout de même
connaissait par coeur on regarde tout de
suite on voit le style des années 80
style des années 2000 on ait du mal bien
au style des années 2020 ce qui définit
ce qui définit une époque ses leçons
en fait c'est sans son ski ce qui a
marqué les années 60 70 c'était c'était
ce sont très chauds vintage des amplis
guitare avec certains année instruments
spécifiques les années 80 où amener
quelque chose de beaucoup plus froid
avec des sons beaucoup plus synthétique
et chimiques
ça continue à évoluer je crois que ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a maintenant de nos
jours c'est un son avec une un spectre
de fréquence est très très large il ya
beaucoup de bas beaucoup de goût
beaucoup de seube beaucoup d'aigus très
aigu et pas mal d'espacés en fait on est
on est revenu à quelque chose de très
[Musique]
très épuré en fait très éthéré
et comme si on avait envie de revenir à
l'essence des choses on s'encombre de
beaucoup moins de choses maintenant
beaucoup moins de deux couches
d'arrangements dans tous les sens moi je
continue à apprécier énormément la
musique instrumentale avec des
instruments jouets et organique
mais je suis fasciné par ce qui se passe
au niveau du son de nos jours
vous écoutez c'est réjouissant parce que
souvent on se dit depuis qu'on fait de
la musique sur les instruments sur les
instruments chinois ça sonne but pareil
donc je ne suivrai pas comment le son
est très très en fait un peu finalement
parce que le bleu le mot qui peut
définir tout ça c'est le sait la fusion
le fait qu'on soit en train de fusionner
à tous tout ce qui nous a nourris et
pendant si longtemps et qui est
maintenant tout le monde peu importe peu
importe son son pays peut proposer une
musique moderne à qui va être accessible
à tous
c'est ça qui est fascinant merci les
chica d'être venu cette fois sur ce
plateau vous serez le 25 juin à la salle
gaveau puis dans absolument toutes la
france pendant tout l'été
sacré tournée je remercie aussi mes deux
autres invités je vous remercie vous de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]